deep drop this time the home swings her
right side wide open
Sammy Watkins again 2015
touchdown it's a semi rockets Palooza
touchdown Kansas City 150 yards
receiving in a quarter for Sammy Watkins
unbelievable day for the fourth overall
pick in the 2014 draft guy who was taken
ahead of players like Gordo Beckham jr.
and Aaron Donald disappointing for most
of his career
had shown flashes flashed in a huge way
on Sunday 9 catches 198 yards three
touchdowns he told si.com I think I got
that mojo back the confidence go out
there and make plays and make moves and
guys they're gonna need him because
Watkins also thinks that Tyree kill will
be gone six or seven weeks with a
collarbone injury that did not require
surgery but that will put him on the
Shelf Peter King do you think Sammy
Watkins can continue this or was it just
kind of a once every five or six weeks
development you know Sammy Watkins his
deal always been he can't stay healthy
he's been he's been extremely fragile so
I don't know if he can continue it we'll
see he's never been able to be great for
a full season this is the biggest reason
you know the the fact that they weren't
sure about Tyreke he'll and they don't
know really about the long-term health
of Sammy Watkins that's why you you do
the shocking thing kind of on draft day
and take McCole Hardman if they started
this season with three receivers they
could play in a three receivers set Hill
Watkins Hardman who are all sub four
three five guys who has that I bet
that's never happened in NFL history and
and so now they've got to it's still you
know a very wealthy position for the
Kansas City Chiefs and obviously now if
Watkins does stay healthy for the next
two months
I don't think Patrick mahomes is gonna
be impacted at all yeah Mike I don't I
mean as Sammy Watkins is healthy that's
the question Peter's right you guys know
that I mean he can be a superstar
there's no doubt about that size speed
can run away from people you know yards
after catch and I do think we'll
continue to see this statistical
explosion why because Tyree kills not
there so now Andy Reid's main focus when
he does orchestrate a gameplan on a
week-to-week basis will be okay here's
my Sammy Watkins plays and then it'll
filter down to the rest of the guys from
there but he becomes prime
suspect number one - get the ball - now
in the passing game you know nobody
cares about your fantasy team but I do
go get me coal Hardman yeah the waiver
wire he's gonna get involved this week
me coal Hardman you know you heard his
name a couple of times he didn't do much
though but he's gonna have some
opportunities with Tyree kill out yeah
we'll be in
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports